okay for people who are joining this
livestream we are talking about some new
machine learning features particularly
neural net related ones for the upcoming
version of Wolfram language and needless
to say there's a eleventh-hour addition
to the documentation that's happening
even as we speak
um alright so let's get
oh boy
Wow this is kind of complicated okay
okay let's just take a look at what
we're roughly looking at here um so
training metrics let's see what is the
point here so
NAT port of loss one I don't really
understand this okay so help me out
um sure I mean the big picture is that
until now we've had a somewhat been
somewhat hard-coded set of metrics so
just the total loss which of course is
you know what drives the training and
then as of the last version the the
error rate for full classification type
of the type training though it can I
update the docs you can okay go ahead
and there's a there's a whole kind of
jungle of metrics beyond just error rate
and many of them are classifier
measurements and so what what we doing
here is we we kind of giving away for
people to request some of those metrics
to be able to see them plotted during
training and there are other ways that
they can use those metrics so after
training they could get like a history
of that of that metric and they could
also observe the metric from callback
functions that's another important thing
and that metric could also be used to
hold influence when training stops but
like if that metric stops improving then
that can be a signal that range
terminated and then there two kinds of
metrics there's gonna be built in ones
and there's going to be user provided
once the user provided ones will be
provided via a port and the built-in
ones will be from a fixed sort of list
of things we have built-in support for
okay so net port is tapping off
something in the main in the network
right yeah yeah and if it's a single
string that's an awkward port but if
it's a hierarchical kind of list then
there can be some internal and what is
the rol to mean that
aggregation so if the if the thing
you're tapping off is not as an array
then the metric does eventually need to
become a scalar value so that you can
plot it and so what is what is l2 that
is Elton that's the outer norm or what
yeah exactly it's the ultra normal but
why isn't that a function I mean
ultimately that's going to be an array
that's coming out of that why is that
thing somehow not a function there well
it would be nice if we had a function
called l2 norm but fit what what will l
2-norm do you give it a tense and it
gives you the old to norm of the tensor
no isn't that just norm its normal of
hash comma - maybe no norm of the thing
comma - yes which doesn't strike me as
the most difficult function I think it
defaults to the l2 norm actually
you
okay
could be things as well so like the
actual list which I'd not sure have
written there obvious things are like
total max mean and so on
but it's a little bit different from our
ordinary meaning of total because I
wouldn't a meeting for total doesn't
it's only totals to level one you know
yeah I don't know what is that a son I
don't know what exactly they call that
that's not the most important thing we
can check back with my traders um let's
see actually we have two questions on
our live stream which we'll try to
address but but then one is will Gann
training be supported
should I answer that now you can answer
that if it's quick we already support a
form of gand training where we
simultaneously train that generating the
discriminator that's actually a known
style of training of gans a confirm the
exact inference we do not support
alternating training unless you call net
train yourself alternating which can be
slow we do have a design for that but
not for version 12 the state of
optimizing it last it's the state of the
optimize we also get lost if you call
the train yourself in an alternating
fashion right so do we do have a design
for the for the alternating gans
strategy we do but it's it's complicated
it's not it's you know I think at all it
will change before we are happy with it
but the basic rough idea is that you
specify multiple you kind of have an
association of different networks right
instead of one network and then you
actually specify multiple net trains
worth of spec along with the schedule
for how to switch between them that's
the real that's the key idea let's just
you know how to present that is the
tricky part
right well several people on a live
stream are encouraging gans so suggest a
design guys then um some is asking about
multi GPU support an efficient training
in the cloud yes it is coming temporal
convolution networks more effective than
L STM's GI use what is the story with
that well we we have read that paper I
don't have a particular pin in on on
whether that's that case has been
successfully made that Elliston should
be abandoned right okay separate
separate story all right let's go back
to this this is complicated stuff okay
so what
what are we supposed to be looking at
here so this is the training metrics
option two
not quite understand how is it by
default using the training network so if
I if I give that as an option can I can
I run this somewhere by the way can I
run it on product I build no that's not
even implemented yet we're in the
process of
Jamie and I on the process of
implementing that okay um
okay someone is commenting that using
often language for Kegel competitions is
enjoyable but I have to hack around the
lack of mean IOU metrics any comments on
that
I mean it's another random metric yes we
could yes I'm a metric for object
detection so it would be something nice
to have at some point okay sounds like
we have at least one vote for it there
okay um all right so what is this an
option - is this an option to clap to
net train or what yes it is littering so
should I open the net train page sure
there's an option to anything other than
that train Y is another way who is
working through I don't know who works
through these these some keyword
resolutions I have not seen those before
okay do we have a project manager hidden
here yes okay do you know the procedure
for this this looks like Phillip added
these things fairly really added them
last month so why don't we find out how
they they seemed quite sensible why did
he add them and how do we who gets to
approve them so they go live okay
alright so are you saying even you've
added this this option or I have to add
this option well we didn't want no we
haven't written the documentation for
this we want you to approve the rough
design or help us kind of decide what
training progress checkpointing was your
last adventure in this right
so you're not and max training rounds so
okay so training metrics is supposed to
be an option that goes in here so what
does training metrics actually do so
it's it's a request so it's a list of
things that you would like access to and
access means several things it means
they will be plotted okay I understand
so let me give you an analogy to this
okay which is handler function keys you
know those things yep um so that's the
thing that determines when a handler in
an asynchronous call what is going to be
provided to the handler
so arguably
this isn't training metrics it's
training metric keys but then what is it
going to what function is going to call
this you can scroll down a little bit I
do mention that in the in the snow
pockets underneath the training metrics
section
it certainly will be added to the list
of things
oh it's doc how do we present metrics
losses to callbacks yeah
these need to be printing the callback
Association that all callbacks get given
callbacks our training produced by :
trading progress function ok so let's
look at the training progress function
ok
we're associations
with the following keys okay so these
keys are being supported but there are
additional ones that you are proposing
could be added to this list that are
being specified by the
you know by these training keys correct
right so and these are you're providing
these ones because they're cheap is that
right
cheap and useful they will the this the
story is actually changing quite a lot
and the reason is that this metric thing
will subsume some of these right and
also there's another feature in this
notebook called
I call history property histories
feature also subsumes a huge chunk of
things hold on let's let's unravel this
for a second ok so so um basically what
you're saying is this is
[Music]
you
okay so first point um
let's see this training metrics is
really training keys or something here's
why I don't agree with with that name
it's that it's putting the emphasis on
the callbacks but for most users they're
not really they're unlikely to look at
it in a callback there anyone to see it
plotted okay so wait so are you saying
that by default training metrics will
cause these things to be plotted it will
certainly do that yes and as a side
effect it will be available in callbacks
or what but are these things that you're
proposing here are they sufficiently
expensive that we can't provide them oh
I see you're saying training metrics
could be the l2 aggregation of that net
port but then how do I refer to that
thing if that is really a key what is
its name here that's a good question so
that's in that's in the final paragraph
of this section oh that's horrifying is
this is this the proposal no that's a
short name so that would be for plotting
purposes where it has two bits more
important that it's just human readable
minutes yeah okay so what are you
proposing here what what is this so if
you go down to the final paragraph
that's oh my gosh look at this
horrifying stuff
so you're proposing that this type of
thing be able to be one of the so you're
proposing that any of the things that
are in here I could say f1 score
interval arrow round or something is
that right sure
I mean that that that precedent is
applies to a lot of these things is that
they support either spec or open list
spec comma interval error or something
like it's true of the training previous
functions for example you know you can
configure them there's a sort of default
and then you can also configure them
with these sub-options oh boy okay but
but then this stuff is just some random
you know it's like that has nothing to
do with with keys or anything that just
has to do with hello this is for
plotting sure yeah I mean but it's you
know that's what you do with metrics
right you see them at the end and you
prop them or you use them to determine
whether you're gonna stop so I mean to
me this is okay so there's two things
that come out of these metrics one is
that they're plotting destination so to
speak and the other is they're keying
their users keys which will then be fed
into other functions is that correct
hello it's the default action so let me
just understand
so here the default action for a
training default usage or the training
metric
is what is plotted correct is that
that's it yeah I think that is the use
pace that most people will want from
training metrics as they will want to
just be able to look at it while the
network of training okay but so what
about somebody who wants it as a key but
doesn't want to plot it that that I'm
skeptical that that even occurs and the
reason is that this is another thing
that you should have client on obviously
but for plotting its gonna get out of
control if you have if we if we
introduce even one more thing like one
more metric we've already got lost and
errors okay and that's that's already
occupies quite a bit of space so if you
start introducing any more metrics that
kind of gets ludicrous and so we now
know we have don't we have those
multi-pane display well we don't have it
but yes that's what I want to do and to
handle the explosion of metrics and that
you're not penalized for having you know
and in that case the fact that there'll
be another button on the panel this is a
relevance like you don't have to look at
it if you don't want to look at it the
default would be lost okay
and there's another point as well it's
another one of these sections in this
notebook which is there's an obvious
thing we've been missing for all these
versions I don't know why we didn't
think of it and that is do you recall
training progress reporting goes to
panel that is the current default
the ephemeral panel what we've been
missing is training progress reporting
goes to window
and what window would do is pop up a
window with the panel in it maybe taking
a little bit more in the car example
does it go to your web browser and pop
up another window in the cloud well it's
not even it doesn't even work in the
cloud because it requires two high
refresh rates to be usable on the cloud
so even panel doesn't work in the cloud
what does the cloud do I figured prints
by default which is what also happens on
the console
okay is that something that could be
fixed because I don't think it really
does it really require that higher
refresh rate I mean why not just reduce
the refresh rate it's I'll make a note
of that let's I will look into that
thing's mine so what I would imagine is
update interval yeah option okay yeah it
is ready and update interruption but the
question is I suppose that you're asking
is and it's a good question no there are
separate for what net train for training
previous reporting oh I see it's a sub
option of that maybe it shouldn't be
and it all goes to you oh boy
pretty wild okay all right fine okay so
with the reason the reason I mentioned
the window thing is first of all do you
what do you think of the idea I think
it's I hope you agree no no no it's it's
a great piece of functionality I've just
worried about the many many many
tentacles that it starts introducing mmm
sure because I mean it's not a common
thing you know except for things like
notebook open and system open and so on
we're not you know opening random
windows with wild abandon yeah exactly
but it does have a very nice property
that that when I've mentioned this to
other people they've all said oh that's
good and that is that it it means that
the the window doesn't that the losses
that the beautiful curves we made don't
disappear as soon as trainings finished
over it so you're not garbage collect in
the window it's a non modal dialogue
effectively is that right yep
so it so it goes to its final state and
then it sits there
yeah like your original net train would
have returned but the window will be
store well let me point out there's
another case which is you can have the
panel not disappear I mean the panel is
currently a print temporary you could
have that panel just sit there after the
ending you know within the main notebook
after the ending of the net train what
should we call that permanent panel
persistent panel
I don't assistant pool that seems
actually honestly more useful than the
random window one because it's like I'm
just worried that there's so many
different issues that come up with when
you're popping up around in window on
the screen how big is it where does it
go you know what happens in this case
you know etc etc etc so the nice thing
would be if we could make it really big
and then you'd have like a much more
detailed view of oil clots could make it
easier to enter those BOTS what happens
if you resize the window with the panel
in it I mean it's very easy to make the
window non resizable I could want it I
think we'd want to do that so that we
can guarantee it lays out in a nice way
I'm sorry you want the which the panel
non resizable no the window if we do
have a window position window
yeah I'll give it four I'd see what you
saying that it's a kind of it's a it's a
is a president breaking thing though I
mean for doing that is that you know
your mother doing this that you always
do that tally but never mind that
okay is that in other frameworks I mean
like intensive close to has this thing
called tensor board for example and it's
a very detailed and rich kind of
environment for interrogating training
as it's happening and it's the kind of
thing that that gets awkward to fit that
into a panel without it sort of
dominating the entire screen right and
being quite a noxious there are lots of
interesting comments in our live stream
but one has just caught my eye here is
is some somebody promoting the window
idea as long as it launches a sub kernel
so you can keep computing in your
notebook and there it's what I the
tentacle start start grabbing strangling
us when session submits actually be a
straightforward solution to that that
request
yes session submit does that but whether
session submit I mean is this notebook
I'm confused I mean the fact is if yes
if you want to do net train with session
submit that should just work do you
think it does work I'm gonna try quickly
one-line it's just a one-line one-liner
fine and then we'll get back to this
okay so what do you want to do you want
to do a net train on something like this
is a document in syntax that maybe
people on the live stream will enjoy use
the string in the net Oh first argument
to net rent gosh okay and then use the
second string m missed oh I love the way
that this is just one of these random
undocumented things
why don't we document that that's that's
the equivalent in that train of net
model of Lynette's right exactly it is
and the second thing is resource data
basically try that oh yeah I don't see
why we shouldn't document this it seems
like a good thing to me um okay so you
want me to try it here
well that's not encouraging is it why
isn't it running okay
we should document this that's very nice
okay dandy all right now you want me to
do session submit of that yeah
you
you
great now what happened I don't know
okay what would you have expected that
to do well I mean that does represent a
task that's running in a in a sub kernel
yes it does a task or not and how would
one not would narrowly know I mean
haven't used this feature much how would
one know when that is finished
oh you K you can you can basically say
you can ask for tasks
what do you ask for you ask for
I think you just asked for the
properties of the task object to find
out what's happening with it there's a
task wait or something that you would
synchronized oh yeah but that's for
synchronization that's not what I want
it's super bad sign that I've got a
spinning wheel here so remember sessions
submit actually submits to run this in
the idle time of the session ah okay
Sushma is here right yes please take a
screenshot please report this I bet that
this is so so much for tasks for this
running asynchronously there
this is tangling itself up with the
pre-emptive kernel nonsense yeah I mean
yeah if that task is running in a
pre-emptive I mean the things you can't
do in a pre-emptive evaluation right
including crazy library link stuff well
I'm not sure about that but but I you
know if you thought that this was going
to bring up a window even though you
submitted asynchronously then you're
definitely wrong about that so what is
that what is this sub task is that task
submit rather than session submit
local submit look I mean cloud submit
submits to the cloud local submit
submits to your local machine and that
creates a sub kernel this is within the
same look this would be a much more
sensible thing local submit of this will
be much more sensible session submit is
really trying to run it within your you
know actually within this process right
which is like very you know scary make
sense yeah so if we do
we could just ask for task status of
that
you
running how helpful um yeah I mean it's
going to do it's going to be a you know
a tree falling in the forest with nobody
to listen because it's not didn't do
anything at the end of this it's just
gonna say great I finished it does it
return the value that that that
expression yielded not unless look
evaluation results Chile that's the
answer yes and that's a complex right
that is actually an answer yes that is
the answer so we can say percent one
evaluation result yeah we just changed
the way that works in the cloud so the
evaluation results and just go away
immediately okay in any case um okay
somebody's pointing out go ahead it
should be done by not like 30 seconds or
so well then maybe that's because it's
no longer available if we do a task
status there it still says it's running
anyway you were saying I was saying um
someone on the live stream is pointing
out that the net trained panel has a
tendency to Fried's the front end it
would be nice to add a display refresh
rate so one of the causes for that so
I've seen this alliance is if a network
takes a long time to evaluate the
network evaluation at the moment is not
servicing pre-emptive evaluations so for
slow networks it'll freeze the front end
that's not good so okay so what's the
solution there the solution is to
basically run everything in separate
threads no I mean that's the solution
for us but it's the solution okay yeah
explain so you're saying that doing
changing the display read a display
refresh rate wouldn't have an effect
that correct yeah exactly it's just if
any if any function call takes more than
five seconds then the front-end will
complain and then warn about tonight
evaluations anybody talk to the the
people who know about the the whole
dynamic mechanism about that is there
any other solution to that there might
be it's boys a while ago
I will check okay um okay okay before we
get back to the site a few other
comments from our livestream how about
something similar the function
repository but for custom untrained nets
Wyatt why isn't one just putting those
in them and then neural net repository
that there are then all that repository
does not require that networks be
trained there's an untrained network
component
isn't that correct it is correct yeah so
those could be in there all that
repository see previously so I guess the
one thing that was previously before
twelve is that you can't have something
like parametrized networks or build a
function like I would have to live in
the function repository so you could say
I want these number of fragments
okay so parametrized networks are coming
to the net repository is that is that
happening is that has that happened yet
or is that that's happening it is right
yes we waiting on a single change to go
through - okay that's gonna be all these
all these things that say I mean like
these are going to be parametrized Nats
is that true for instance I think you
have endless language models right which
are going to be prioritized by language
for example yes there'll be tons of
those and there will be this case of
infinite families of models where you
specify things like the depth or you
know the width of of of a specific kind
of like silly net is the classic example
next point not try not to be able to
more clearly to be able to do everything
that classify and predict can do with
method - arrow neuron that's eg utility
function
I don't know about that I mean only
recently has has classified with neural
Nets been dramatically improved you guys
haven't been the ones involved in that
have you I have been someone involved so
I propose the methods a while back
so yes it's is basically soft
normalizing networks which give very
competitive performance for things like
random forests so knows better okay so
Sarah is recommending that we look at
his posts or more from community about
utility function and so on so perhaps
Sushma can surface that um someone is
asking here about custom layers yes
indeed custom layers are in under
development I don't know whether though
are they even good to make it in some
experimental form for 12 maybe maybe
it's maybe an internal and internal
context but um not in a way that you
could we can guarantee it'll be
unchanged for 12.1 on I mean so like we
might there might be a sneak peek these
different kinds of customers though
right like net function is not really a
custom layer what is it I thought
function what yeah it's it's it's a new
network as a program so you're saying
what you're saying is I don't know what
we've been calling it what are we
calling custom layers function layer is
that right which can have arbitrary code
in it yeah it'll be a tree in the sense
that it's have to be compatible with the
new compiler right and you specify both
the Ford function and also the gradients
function so it's you have complete
control over anybody know if they if the
current version of the compiler is in
the head branch build it wasn't
yesterday I think
that overtime is that a 12.1 or is it a
12-point x which the compiler 1x point x
yeah compiler will be in 12 point Oh
some version of the compiler will be in
12 point oh I mean we can put an earth
did this just do oh I see so if I say
function compile of
actually I have to remember how to use
all of the stuff um a function I mean
all of this what's that now looking it
is it is latest version it is in the
latest version seems like its function
compiles to find C so if this works um
but then this should do you know if
they'll if if it's in if the
oh for goodness sake well who knows oh
maybe this needs an it's just so you see
this is low-level nonsense right
the cooks it's just yeah it's just okay
there it is horrifying
um yeah good so what's more interesting
I think is if this is working um
what is it called export compiled the
compiled code export function maybe
Sushma remembers what that's now called
Punk function compiled export but we
actually wants okay because that will
produce the raw embed codes pieces of it
our embed code there's three separate
functions as function compile export
this function compile exports string and
these all do different things because
they're producing dot o files or they're
producing assembly Lite assembler code
or other things so different stuff um
let's see um okay someone's commenting
that something is a perfect place to use
the annotation design discussed in a
previous stream I'm guessing
oh I'm not exactly sure what they were
talking about but it might have been
this business about the plot labels and
so on I agree that is a good comment um
okay and
let's see
no good way to evaluate networks that
are trying to do regression predictor
measurements should be able to take
train net graphs also now we agree we do
agree and predictive net would make a
predictor that's an interesting idea
so no it's if you give a network what's
that yeah we agree okay all right let's
go back to back to business here um okay
so looking at this again so you're
saying training metrics gives a list of
things that will be plotted
and which are also available as keys to
compute from is that correct yes and so
I think that the order of importance is
one the plotting to once the thing is
finished training the training results
object should you have used that should
you've asked for that will contain the
final values of those metrics because
it's one thing to like see things
visually and it's another thing to you
know once you finish training okay what
is the name of a thing of a weird
creature like this so that's a good
question I mean my but my bias is that
if you gave a string like precision or
recall that's a perfectly good name okay
so I've got a suggestion here so why not
have training metrics have the
possibility of being an association and
then what you could do is you could say
precision arrow and maybe this is
completely crazy
yeah this may be crazy I mean cuz well
I'm what I'm trying to do is to get some
way to name this thing here yeah you
know what you know what you know what
the right way to do this is the
following
okay either you just say precision so
it's a bulk thing or you say something
like um metric arrow whatever that thing
is um and then you say display style
arrow plot style arrow blah blah blah
you say you know key name or key arrow
blah blah blah right so here if you
wanted to so in other words you have a
choice if you're gonna use if you really
want this net Portero l2 to be available
as a key see what I'm saying you do
something like this
makes sense so that is the that's where
the key would be picked up for use in
the in the training whatever it is is
well you'd never I mean that would be a
terrible name for a key given that you
could use a nice short string no I know
I know I know the keys name could be
Fred here Yeah right but that's my point
my point is that that you have a choice
you either get to specify in the
training metrics some bulk thing like
recall okay
or you say I'm good I want to give
details in which case puff it out until
its destination okay I like that and
then and then it means that we don't
even need to use that arrow syntax fo2
we could say aggregation goes to l2 and
have a great curve much better much much
better um all right cool I mean the
thing is we should really have done this
with all these other places that had
spec followed by a bunch of sub options
and we can can change those I think we
should okay where am i saving this
Sushma
Neera let's let's aim look thanks
Sushma could you email that to us
afterwards yeah I think any opinion what
this should be okay I'm just gonna label
this is an SW notes okay um
okay let's keep going here alright so so
that's the approach we're going to take
on that and then what we have to read
occupant then in the progress reporting
function etc is just that any additional
keys made available by training metrics
will be available so to speak right yeah
okay cool
all right so all of this stuff here will
just go into that Association this
interval etc etc should be called
interval that's what we use elsewhere
okay and you've got oh my gosh I I'm not
leaving them begin with the level of
total weirdness that you're adding here
we don't plan to support my function
reduce function for 12 although we might
best okay so here in terms of this is a
display thing I don't think slash is a
great thing there I would use some
unicode character so I'm greater than
sign type thing or some designed glob so
people don't get confused it should be
an option I mean I don't know if it's
called plot name or prop table or
something but the default has to be
something well what's the analogous
thing would be it will be a legend right
what would be the name in or whatever it
could be I don't know where the plot
name is a very good very good word for
it because I think there's an analogous
thing in the case of a an ordinary plot
I mean that's more like it
no plot labels for the whole plot plot
legend is is more than analogous thing
yeah okay you know what I think the
right thing is is something like short
name because we will use this somewhere
else too which is we will use it in
reporting when we when we literally that
we read them know when we literally
lists the value there's a little bit you
know like it can you quickly or can you
do a net train just so we can see what's
in there okay so you're suggesting I
mean because this would be plot legend
would be the appropriate name for this
there but you're also suggesting short
name right and there might even be a
long name as well in principle okay so
you want me to do a net train III you
know we should say we should document
this this is nice is that correctly
spelled Lynette M list I mean you've got
I've needed to do this a million times I
should have I should have thought that
you would put in one of these weird
ergonomic thingies brilliant okay that
version 12 prototype build prototype
Portland's broken
[Music]
you
in fact do one more we've got an enable
dynamic evaluation do one more thing set
validations you need an option
validation set goes to enlist as well
why okay all right so good because it
because it'll show you why I dislike the
legend
you
you
you
okay there's a radio legend that applies
to all parts and it contrasts validation
with training that legend will kick in
listen as you've got to the end of this
of this round you'll see the blue dot
it'll take a while do the following can
you quickly do sorry about this
can you quickly change emili´s to ms
sample the string just tech the word
samehada let's have this go in the
background and let's talk about some
other things okay okay so um okay
so
thing about these history things I
wonder I want to dig into that for a
minute yeah short oh okay oh boy
what is all this this is it's actually a
relatively simple feature and it's it's
the point that when the validation
usually lasts or error starts to go up
again then you
there's no point training anymore
because your net has begun to overfit
sis preventer memorized and so we don't
most most like Karis let's you very
easily stop as soon as it happens
because it's quite mechanical to
determine I mean I think the syntax is
kind of suboptimal right I mean so so
more this would be something like loss
arrow Association blah blah blah no
because you don't combine this with
there's one thing you look at you don't
look at several things simultaneously
you're looking at several things here no
those are just best those are just
details of the loss you see that you
want so you're looking at loss and you
want to make if it goes down by 5% and
you keep training
I understand I mean this is fairly
grotesque syntax
okay I mean of those your blue dot by
the way look my general attitude towards
all of this stuff is I still consider
the world of you know this is the
assembly language of you know machine
learning programming what we're doing
right now you know most of what um um
you know most actual usage in the future
will be at a higher level than all of
this stuff this is still because this is
an emerging area and people are still
worrying about whether the optimal way
of you know doing some you know they'll
be like being able to set weird things
about your CPU about you know cache
persistence in your CPU um it's not that
so I'm not making that's why I'm not
being more sneaky about some of this
design because I think it's really
low-level stuff that is going to be
eventually subsumed in and other things
do you disagree with that point of view
I I mean I'm trying to imagine today you
don't really have very many assembly
programmers right if your argument is
correct you're kind of implying making
instead ten years no one will ever be
writing code like this that was correct
and I'm I'm not the same reason the same
thing has happened in numerical analysis
there was a time when people were full
of you know where they were tweaking
every possible parameter of an
optimization function for example and
then they just said forget it some
library does this you know and minimize
does this let's not worry about it
that's what I think is gonna happen I
see in fact I'm sure it's gonna happen
which is why I'm not worrying that these
things are rather you know this will be
some low level set of tentacles that are
important for getting it right but are
not um okay I you know this syntax is
pretty horrifying to me but whatever and
this here what is this how do you
combine this with something like this we
don't
so what lost means is you want the last
to improve all you stop training but you
can define your own function that says
what
prove means no no what is this stuff
here
okay so the property history stuff is I
think it's much you know it's um it's a
much more high level thing so it might
be more to your taste basically that you
returned the history of something that
thing could be a property though or it
could be a function itself which depends
on though right do you want to comment
on anything to do with this panel over
here my only point is that the legend
there contrast training and validation
set and fundamentally that's what the
word legend that's why I don't like the
word legend and I wear the juice find
the poison okay fine I I don't have a
brother
um okay
okay let's sum let's go back over here
so you're saying this is part of net
train
this is the return values
from that train ah we have certain
return values right now right yeah
so we've we've hard-coded a bunch of
these histories I fan an explosion is
it's exploded and I want to unexploded
and in fact I want to make it much more
powerful by just letting you
parameterize what you want to record
over the duration of training how are
you giving aren't you giving a net train
aren't you saying there's a list of
things that you could return right so it
needs to be it's not actually ambiguous
because this is not one of those things
I'm sorry what are you saying so here
there's a property specific property but
you can give a list of properties to
return yes you can't give them a
supercut easier
okay fine so given that what are you
proposing here so this list is a
different kind of list I mean we could
call it history I actually called it
history before that's the first string
there but just to be clear that whole
tupple of list weights interval goes
around that is one it's identifying one
no no I realized that I realized that
I'm complaining about the fact that
that's ambiguous with well it's
generally not it's not ambiguous because
list itself is not a property
oh for goodness sake are you suggesting
okay you're suggesting that this here
okay so you said this is crazy
I mean yes it's really crazy let's clean
it up okay we can clean it up
well it was my notebook from before look
basically what you're saying is I don't
really like this very much anyway but
but um uh what version of my in um
that is really odd where was I actually
doing this stuff
it's here okay all right so what I'm
suggesting is if that first thing there
okay so you're saying it's net train of
net data properties correct return what
you should return right yep yeah and
what's the default thing that it returns
trained net right yeah okay so now what
you are saying is you want to in
addition return so for example let's
imagine that you want rms weights which
apparently is not something you can
return on its own
um yeah so in the new world you would
ask for that I know how you would ask
for that it would be horrifying I mean
but what you could say is that property
could be history arrow RMS weights
conceivably okay sure rather than
because otherwise you get in the
situation so then what you can do is
you're either asking for you know so in
this case what you would do I don't
really like this but you can say train
net history arrow RMS weights that's the
next thing you're asking for
look ultimately I mean that might be a
shorthand but ultimately you're going to
want something like this you're going to
want an association there so it's either
train net or it's the association which
is something like payload or indicator
or say indicate it's not really an
indicator it's what is it because it
could be the Train Network mean suppose
it's a property well okay all right so
let's say let's try calling it property
[Music]
and let's see so we call it property and
we call it something like um output form
or something I don't even know if that's
right
I don't know output arrow evolution plot
or something I mean this is horribly
kind of Bank switched stuff
you
you know you suggesting something like
this property output
you know output our Oh history something
like that history list um so yeah I mean
so you're suggesting that either
it's just trained net maybe there's a
shorthand for a case like this or it's a
full Association which says what your
what you're getting like RMS weights
that'll quite often be a function and
then precedence works against the error
unfortunately well tough luck
that's okay
which will be a function the thing that
you recording um but it's not just
recording right it's it's something
where I mean this is and I don't know
what would happen if you say you know
what you're delivering is the train net
charge I mean it works today
no no what you're delivering is the
train net but the output format you want
is an evolution plot that's well I know
you can't I know you come that's not a
good design if it isn't because what
you're saying is that there are some
indicators here that you can do like
even batch size it's not something
you're gonna be able to do you know an
aggregation whatever so really what
you're talking about is you've got two
categories of thing here you've got
things like train net that just are what
they are right and then you've got a
category of thing where some of which
have nice convenient names like error
rate evolution plots but you say I want
to be able to parameterize a rate
evolution plot so then what I'm
suggesting is yeah that that term
um
okay so this is what I'm suggesting um
whatever that was error rate
or quantity except we tend to use that
ok quantity format
evolution plot and then something about
how for that you might want even more
detail interval blah blah blah
okay so what I'm suggesting then is that
your alternatives are you either say I'm
cutting this out because I don't believe
in this you either say trained net or
the next thing that could be in that
list is oh and I also want this error
rate with this decoration that makes
sense
yeah I understand um I'm not sure about
quantity I'm not sure that name is right
what should it be value
but can be folks and it could be
something like knit no it cannot be
something like now to anything because
that's kind of silly if you do that if
you saves formats look these these well
okay fair enough you could decorate it
that way all right fine
property or a rate format evolution plot
makes sense sure yeah yeah okay all
right so we have a solution for this
here right yeah can we look at the
weights example can you just can you
mind doing this quickly with with the
eminence think because precisely because
it is so easy to to try it out
could you try yeah okay hold on a second
we have to push back we have another
meeting about chemistry that is coming
up very soon
you
okay go ahead let me try it
so it's Lynette and then in a sample
because we want to hold on I just want
to know um of the stuff that we have to
do here can we please prioritize a
little bit um yeah I mean you're
complaining about some aspect of the
syntax is that correct
Kalli not switch the syntax it's it's
that I mean I'm willing to lose the
fight on syntax but I just want to make
sure that we support this transpose list
thing as well and you'll see what that
is when I demonstrate I did when i if I
can demo it to you okay what do I do
so learn it and then M lists except in a
sample so you want me to net train on
that and please switch whether that's
for you to remember to deal with
documenting this by the way is M this
sample something that's in the data
repository no why don't we put it there
we could I suppose okay look I can
clearly do this come on I can do this
if you care about Edna's sample and if
you want that fancy syntax to work then
you've got to have hope how big a sample
five hundred a thousand oh you know why
because that's you using 11.3 probably
yeah use like use a thousand
you
is this 11:3
how am i doing dynamic updating enabled
okay what are you trying to show here
Kali hello what are you showing here
sorry sorry third argument could you do
um can you forget could you hello yes
I'm here third argument yes what so do I
give and do open list this is the
Cranston text list in the string like a
lot of the word list okay comma and then
knit as a string yeah is this 11 3 could
you do you have a secured build of 12 I
don't know what this is doing I'm always
trying to start the [ __ ] tool system um
let me get ready to share in case I need
to need to do this myself
because of your build I don't know what
this is doing
I know so you got to do there's a bug in
this prototype you've got to do interval
goes to quantity one round sorry about
that
interval goes to what one city one round
yep and then you might have to do first
not wait forever max training rounds
goes to like 10 or something what we're
trying to see the result here yeah it's
just actually verify that this is
working because the actual thing I want
you to run is slightly different
I forgot the sake okay so that'll be a
list so that'll be a list of nits right
as we expect oh no that's too many could
you so could you just add max Trinitron
goes to five I'm gonna run something
else and then the thing that I'd like
you to run is the second set of NIT try
weights yeah yeah why does it think
weights training learning multipliers as
a thing there - no that should be
checked
Susheela that's for you auto-completion
okay now here's the here's the crucial
point um no it's actually yeah we don't
have an America race yet the problem
here is that this is you see this is a
list of associations right and quite
often you don't want this you want the
other way around so you want an
association of time series right
Association of time series as opposed to
a time series of associations yeah well
yeah a dissociation of lists rather than
a list of associations um
tough luck then you can figure out how
to turn it around I mean it's really
hard there's no so who don't have
association transfers yes so yes we do I
mean at least it's coming in twelve
really as far as I know okay
if it isn't I mean Sushma that's another
thing for you that's supposed to be in
the ILD agenda I thought it was done
no not an ILD at least we are not doing
it for - well I mean oh I mean it's
crazy is okay fine
okay separate branch yeah Association
transposon they identify LD okay but but
that's not we're not introducing a whole
giant syntax here for the sake of the
lack of Association transpose I mean I I
let me sure I don't want to join syntax
at all but um yeah I mean is it so bad
to have form goes to list and then a
form goes to transpose list or something
if it's a string you know I can do that
if you want to I mean formats here for
format is that the right word format
goes to list is it for I mean for
matters has meaning in the language I
know I know I know I know I hope to put
what about form has meaning as well I
think we would generally people would
generally understand format better than
form I think it's okay format list and
transpose list I think that's okay it's
kind of hacky but I think it's okay okay
cool
then I'm happy okay then property is
fine yeah okay cool all right okay
that's that um what's next here so then
do you you prove the removal of this
final prefix this is part of a
rationalization process it's been going
on for a while to collapse together the
keys that you get in the callback
functions with the keys that are
available as properties for net train
itself as final you know so we're about
what if it's a final if you if you go
into netra and you see the things you
can get out then I think it's a final
way it's fun or its vector all of that
stuff it's kind of vestigial it
just from before we realized we could
collapse those two lists of keys
together through what lists of keys
well the Kaiser grounds loss what are
you going to get so that would become
the final round bus right if you ask for
it as a property of net rain because all
of these are basically really one of
these just mean evaluate this thing at
the end get this key at the end well
except when it's not at the end except
when it's a history yeah but those are
going away right
turning into those things yeah so now
that we have this mechanism it's the
final thing that lets us what's the name
for the quotes format which probably
isn't the right name for the thing that
just returns one of it just returns the
last one that's just the property itself
no no no but you might want other
Tentacles in it no those are all relates
to how to collected over time all right
all right fair enough but obviously you
got to continue to support these final
things forever here right but you can
remove them in the documentation I guess
sure that sounds fun to me so you just
say it would end up being the mean loss
achieved yeah cool okay um what is this
learning rate thing we want a new symbol
because it's it's kind of a fundamental
thing this what's the one actually what
units is it in its dimensionless what is
it what what is it if it's a rate it to
something but something I don't know
said step size
I mean Isis stand what roughly what it's
doing it's going but go ahead to explain
well it's a bit weird because the
gradients themselves the whole STD is
itself dimensionally bankrupt
right so the learning rates could be
it's interpreted housing as having a
dimension that makes a dimensionally
workout so basically the problem is that
you want to say updates a parameter and
you want to say D by D something and
that has different dimensions as the
parameter obviously and so the learning
rates could have a I'm convinced by the
naked name learning rate that's what I'm
guess I'm pushing on with audience
dimensions because it's just a weird
thing I mean because learning rate
sounds like the conclusion but it's not
the conclusion it's some parameter in
the discretization of the gradient is
that true yes gradient descent step size
of the gradient that was observed this
size that you actually she's not whereas
learning rate sounds like I'm training
my rat and it learnt this maze you know
one turn per day or something yeah my
philosophy is like a pick your battles
like this is one of the most fun terms
that does we can't add some you know
some decoration to this name that still
makes it recognizable but also makes it
not totally incomprehensible to somebody
I mean this is this is the same thing as
when you're doing optimization if I'm
not mistaken this is I mean it's
basically a it's basically as you say
it's a step size for the discretization
of the gradient is that right it's the
multiplier for the discretized gradient
why not call it learning rate multiplier
as we very good I mean
then I retract it because it's just
going to be embarrassing if it's called
anything other than learning rate
honestly what is learning rate
multipliers that's that's per layer
multipliers so when you want different
parts of the net to learn at different
rates so your claim is we've already
cooked our goose by calling it lowing
rate multipliers I think that's your
claim but I agree with it I think we
have cooked a goose all right all right
growl okay okay um all right we
basically done here there were a few
comments on the live stream that we
could should look at here but um
so thinking I mean if I could sum up I
think we've got you you basically made
this move twice now and maybe you should
make it a third time of going from a
list based some text an association
based on text to deal with complexity
yes and I don't disagree I think it's it
is a bit more verbose than I prefer but
it's probably clearer in the long term
so I don't disagree with that the one
place you didn't do it is in training
stopping criterion we could do it there
so we could say yes let's do it her
property goes to loss something
criterion goes to loss loss I would say
yeah and then the other key strike you
is acceptable
I mean I don't it's relative change okay
so we've got four cases we've got
relative and absolute change and we've
got whether whether it's increasing or
decreasing I don't really understand why
there isn't plus and minus for the
change but whatever do you know why is
that for the relative change
it's then like what is what yeah maybe
no you know why you know why because it
can be zero and then it's ambiguous like
you you allow any change to be
considered an improvement you don't have
a minimum bound on that change so why do
you give a direction at all in that case
because you don't want it to go the
wrong way
you just want it to stay the same what
is the setting in that case what would
be like direction goes to increasing
absolute change goes to zero absolute
change goes to zero is the default
already by the way so because there's no
natural scale for these guys okay I'm
not even gonna ask what units patience
is then that's how many it's this
happens after validation that's how many
times how many validation rounds so it's
and round it's in Ron's so I should play
the quantity there um
fair enough um the function thing we can
defer what function thing the function
spec the green this thing here yeah I
mean it's accept billion it's just
something that returns true false to
whether to stop or not well I think if
you have criterion you know the
association with the criterion and so on
I think that's perfectly reasonable
additional possibility so long as those
keys are of clear origin okay so that is
a thing there's one thing we haven't
decided yet and that is how those key
and it's at the top of your screen okay
there is actually what's tricky is that
they're four separate things
there's metrics and losses that's one
axis and then there's also training and
validation so and then there's these
arbiter these keys that you you yourself
created when you define the metrics
remember with you all right right right
right
have you called it so now do you approve
of you know we need to make those these
values available to the user in inside
callbacks and inside that function there
and the stopping criterion and we kind
of this whole thing stomping on each
other so they've got to be named spaced
somehow and my proposal is what you see
they're four separate associations where
do those appear so those four keys would
be part of the the giant Association
that gets given to every callback
function depends yeah it'll affect it
will always be there they may not be
anything in training a tree I'm not sure
it sounds okay and the quick-thinking
that I'm doing about it right now um we
need to wrap this up let me just um okay
a few comments from people on the
livestream that a feature request for
method arrows super convergence this
okay we're bathing but we're not sure
but we're adding it okay
Pro that they want a progress report on
onyx export that's a good story isn't it
so they'll be onyx import 412 that onyx
expert will probe into 0.1 okay um
being able to question about being able
to use Python and tensorflow libraries
that that is possible with external
evaluate and it's getting better and
better um so there's no way of mixing
tensor flow without your network
framework unfortunately that's but
that's because they're much more
detailed thing but it's a question of of
having um right okay well provide a new
way of constructing Nets eg a functional
specification we've really wanted that
for 12 but we've we didn't have enough
time so that is a twelve point one
feature biggest pain point been that
chain and net graph is trying to debug
why some layers fail to connect I
thought that was all beautifully
automatic what we do try to give good
error messages but you know we can't if
it doesn't make sense then we can't
construct it so it's hard to show
anything but net function will hopefully
have a better story there anyway and I
don't dispute the users implicit claim
that net graph can be hard to you know
hard to build I already do think net
function is going to be a like a quantum
leap in economics and Python term I mean
big not small
and you don't me nevermind I um okay a
suggestion of a context menu for
disabled dynamic content that is very
reasonable and I don't know why that's
something for the user assistance
meeting um the the gray box that's there
should just sprout a button to re-enable
it
am i making sense Sushma did you
understand that
just that that's a good suggestion which
should have been thought of a long time
ago right um
okay let's see a question from Seth
Chandler here is there any way that the
statistics functional model fit could
accept the same formats as machine
learning obviously it should I don't
know what anybody here is in a position
to discuss that um I'm not quite sure
which aspects of linear model fit are
being discussed here perhaps in terms of
the structure of the data
pretty sure that's pretty mean like
there's lots of variations that the
classified predicted except there are
quite convenience yeah that would be a
good thing to add I mean there's also
some categorical data stuff that needs
to be dealt with for this um yeah that's
a good note I what might work is I mean
the pre-processing that we have as part
of to mention reduce maybe well
pre-processing in general there's a big
pre-processing module and that should be
you know used for linear model fit and
so on
I think that's the main story yeah
all right we have to wrap here um the
linear model fit does not take
associations as data set the saying
that's bad
that's for you to contact Gosha and try
and get go share to talk to a TN who has
a whole bunch of code that does
processing the general pre-processing
furs for classified that's something we
should have picked up actually okay um
alright well for folks on the livestream
thank you for all those comments and we
are about to go to a meeting about
computational chemistry so if you want
to join us join our other livestream
about computational chemistry um and for
the neuron that crew will them do we do
we have more meetings that we need in
this series or is this pretty much it I
think we might mean one more but um
let's make that 4-minute next week if
that's okay
Midway next week okay sounds good talk
to y'all soon thanks bye